great so yeah thanks James for that
introduction so I'm actually to start it
with a little bit of interactive though
and so I want to ask you all a question
so how have you or anyone you know never
been burdened by technology in any way
you think of examples of the time that
you were just annoyed by something or
acting's my battery died early this
morning lies bought the thought again
somehow i'm addicted to listening to NPR
when I should just be relaxing why not
okay so technical failures what else
yeah few weeks scale of the fire alarm
went off in my dorm and I was woken up
by three okay yep so annoyance are
disturbing your sleep yep okay each
other keeps reminding me that I'm not
walking enough feel guilty yep yep yep
uh whatever my computer died i said 'no
seemed like this i'm close to a charter
ok sorry constraining you physically yep
okay anything else yep damn spam yeah so
annoying yet to yes Oh in terms of like
notifications and things like that okay
just cool Chuck phone calls Tony halls
yes I was sitting guilt of being
overwhelmed by all this kind of cannella
no I can't yeah the unit can never keep
on top of things yet anything else
people want to share all right so you
guys did a pretty good job covering so
we did a bunch of interviews and we got
a lot of feedback from people about the
ways that the technology burdens them as
well we talked to them about
specifically what technologies in
particular so we had them talked about
one technology that they were currently
using and talk about the ways it burdens
them and then one technology that they
had actually stopped using for whatever
reason and so this isn't all of them but
some of the things the themes had come
up was that basically they're just not
getting enough value for the amount of
effort they have to put into it it's too
expensive to keep up like people talked
about like oh I just stopped using the
iPad because it broke and it costs six
hundred dollars to replace and I didn't
have the money to use it to replace it
they would forget about it or they were
tired of thinking about it a lot of
times fitness trackers came up in this
category of like gosh II like I forgot
it today and then I stop forgetting it
and then I just stopped thinking about
it
and some people had quit using things
about concerns about privacy they were
worried about becoming addicted to it or
it's impactive of using it in a family
setting or you know things like phones
at the dinner table wall out at
restaurants they're worried about the
impact there or just they they bought
something thinking it was cool and I
just couldn't figure out how to use it
and they trashed it so those are some of
the things that we had come up with so
I'm throughout kind of this big
exploration of the ways that burdens
might place be placed on people while
they use technology we end up developing
a model for this and so the model of
user burden that we've worked on
consists of six different constructs and
so I'll talk a little bit about how we
came up with those particular constructs
but the kind of six overall categories
that we came up with were difficulty of
youth so that includes things like you
couldn't figure it out it was difficult
to learn or also things like I needed
help with this so you think about the
the person who's new to technology
they're constantly having to like beg
their their nephew to come configure it
for them so they just need to help from
people but also people with a disability
who couldn't use it and if they were
visually impaired and they they needed
to always grab a sighted person to help
him configure it we heard about like
game systems and like real video game
systems that always required a sighted
person to turn on in the first place
because it was really difficult to find
the actual button on it and then we had
physical burdens and that was you a lot
of things around the physicality
constraining people two spaces wearing
things though such of things time and
social burdens which is pressures on you
taking up too much of my time as well as
disrupting my social connections as well
so distracting me from family distract
me from friends mental and emotional
burdens I'm going to go and more detail
on each of these but mental emotional
burdens were things like you having to
remember to use it or things making you
feel guilty for example privacy burden
so worried about information being
shared or what's not knowing what's
being collected about them and then
financial burden so it just is too
expensive to buy or maintain so within
our model we made Oh definition of each
of these so for difficulty of you see
the system does not fit within the
abilities of user or is difficult to use
so some of the examples that came up and
are just
questions wasn't actually the the bendy
fork that's impossible to use but I like
that particular one but things like yo
fitness or sorry health-based trackers
that were inaccessible to people with
visual impairments they couldn't use a
their blood glucose meter they were they
were blind because they were diabetic
and they actually couldn't use the the
blood glucose meter because it they
couldn't read the display or things with
a steep learning curve so people
mentioned things like Photoshop right
he's like oh yeah I heard Photoshop is
the greatest thing to do and I like
photography but they open it up and
they're completely overwhelmed and make
it they can't figure at all so things of
steep learning curve spit in this
category the second one was physical
burdens so the system makes the user
physically uncomfortable in in some way
so that could be physically painful so
maybe you guys heard about the version
of fit bid that was actually like
causing rashes on people's hands but
also things like that are uncomfortable
or heavy I was actually one of the
original wearable computers and it was
really funny because they can never get
women to wear these because they were
actually so heavy and it was there
really bulky and heavy so couldn't be in
that way as well but then the physical
constraints as well like having to sit
next to the wall because your court is
there physically constrains you in some
way or exercise technologies that would
you be you bothersome while you're
running a lot of times runners didn't
want to have anything on their bodies
while they're running time and social
burden so and we're building the model
these ended up converging when we did
our analysis but this is that the system
might require a significant amount of
time to use or disrupts the user's
ability to create and sustain social
relationships so the big examples that
came up there were things like you
obviously phones came up a lot yo people
were annoyed of going out to restaurants
with people who would SAT there in their
phone the whole time that definitely
came up a lot but then also things like
just having to remember to use it so
frequently so your phone's getting
notifications all the time or like food
journals that required you like go in
you know like 80 times a day and you
know and that I had a little bite of you
Eminem that I grabbed from there and had
to go in and enter it there so just
having to use it frequently throughout
the day but then also things that annoy
others so we talked about people that
were spamming yo your newsfeed if like I
went out for a run for
three miles lezdom could research by a
stream Fogerty students about what
actually makes that interesting but they
were they felt bad if it was kind of
spamming their friends or with with kind
of uninteresting posts but those were
some of the things that came up in that
category mental and emotional burdens Oh
animation there but this requires the
system to a significant amount of
attention or concentration I could be
distracting makes these are feel bad or
makes them unnecessarily worried so I
don't know where that one came from but
no stray image in there but you'll for
the example we fit you'll fuses if you
were familiar with this game from
Nintendo you act she had a little
platform and you stepped on it and it
would weigh you and it actually make
your Wii Fit character expand and tell
you that's obese and it's like really
kind of nasally voice which is super
annoying and they actually had like
videos of like yo teenagers or like
really young kids being told they're
obese and like crying and so it wasn't
really a fun thing so really made you
feel bad about yourself makes you worry
unnecessarily so this is actually a
personal example of my never know if
anyone has used the delta app before
four flights but um I was flying I think
it was on the flight from Seattle to
Atlanta and it was like a five hour
flight and I pop open my phone I want to
look up where my next gate is and I get
this big red warning saying like my
flight is delayed and the first option I
see is find alternative flight so I was
like oh no crap I'm gonna be late turns
out my flight was one minute late it her
drive it was like supposed to arrive at
704 I got it 705 but it triggered this
big red warning so made me kind of
worried unnecessarily and then things
like requires concentration so like
really complex visualizations or things
like that yeah geez the one where the
warning doesn't it maasai make you worry
but it makes you guys don't work sure
yeah thinking it google maps will show
you maybe shorter rap and it's like one
yeah which maybe is worth it when it's a
four minute trip but like you're up an
hour drive or so okay one minute yeah
yeah so unnecessarily distracting people
typing into that that would fit into
that category as well so it's kind of
distracting unnecessarily that would
come in there as well as you
and yeah anything that requires kind of
significant amounts of concentration as
well fell into this category privacy
burns I kind of talked about a little
bit but the definition was the system
works risks revealing information about
a user that he or she would prefer not
to share so people talked about things
like confusing privacy settings like
maybe they had the ability to go in and
do these things but it was such a burden
to kind of go in and do that and pay
attention to it and the default settings
were bad and they had to where they kept
changing Facebook is notorious for this
so that came up a lot as well as things
like you capturing data or sharing
without transparency so I think people
talked about things like oh I installed
this app and I sign in with Facebook and
before I knew it all my friends got this
like spammy invite and I didn't realize
that I'd give him permission to access
my friends list so those sorts of things
or things like you know people had
wearable cameras and things that are
capturing things without people knowing
and not knowing how to notify them and
so people people also mention things
like drones as well so if you like I'm
worried about my neighbor's drone you
know they capture you're taking pictures
of me inside my window but the last
category was financial burden so this
one's pretty straightforward but
basically costs a lot of money for the
user to initially purchase or maintain
use and this is obviously relative to
the person so you would a lower income
person you having to spend two hundred
dollars on a phone is way outside of
their wares two hundred dollars for
someone who's more well off that may not
be a burden to them so this one is
definitely relative based on the person
but things came up were you know things
that cost too much initially macbooks
came up on that one as well but Google
glass was obviously when that came out
people like there's no way I'm spending
that much money on that and then things
like you expensive to maintain if I
break it or lose it I can't afford to
replace it also things like subscription
fees came up too so if you had to kind
of keep paying overtime then that was an
undue burden for people and so we end up
developing this through the development
of a validated measure called the user
burden scale will be presenting the sec
hi next month actually but basically
what we've done is we've done a bunch of
interviews and created a whole set of
burdens and we develop questions based
on that and the questions when we did
our validity ended up grouping into
these these six categories that I just
described but the scale itself we
basically were designing all these
technology
used and not really insane that we were
trying to reduce the burden but had no
way of actually saying proving that we
had reduced the burden so this is our
way of figuring out how to do that so
end up being a 20-item scale with six
subscales in each of the six categories
and it's designed for both systems that
people are currently using as well
systems that have been abandoned so two
versions of the scale based on the
technology so the example questions are
you know using you you would actually
pipe in the name of the technology so a
facebook or Fitbit or anything along
those lines and a pipe the thing and so
using facebook made me feel like a bad
person was a mental and emotional one i
use netflix more often than i should and
then they can kind of say never a little
bit sometimes we have two different
types of questions there so you can kind
of get a sense of that you know the
systems policies about privacy or not
trustworthy i need assistance from
another person to use that so that's how
they fit into each of those categories
EST i'm going to do that ranks so we
validate with over a thousand people
they got to opt into saying what
technology they want to evaluate and
i'll go through some examples of some of
the stuff that they put in there but
yeah we tested the the validity of the
components using principal components
analysis we did interitum reliability we
did concurrent validity with technology
still in use sources abandoned and so we
were able to show that the scale was
sensitive to being showing that new
technologies that had been abandoned had
higher burden in various categories and
technologies are still in youth and then
we did convergent validity compared to
the system usability scale which
measures kind of the more positive
aspects so user burdens for the more
negative aspects and so and we saw
basically opposite correlation with with
the s us and conversion with along some
of the metrics within the nasa TLX which
measured which measures task load which
is another sort of similar one so the
details are all on our paper which i can
will be at chi next month but it was
basically we have loaded validated
against and the ended up with the six
subscales so we have varying numbers of
questions within each one and so it is
that you if you didn't care about
privacy
some people don't you don't have to
include those questions in the scale or
if you only really care about physical
you're designing a wearable technology
you want to assess physical you can only
use that so the skills valid within each
of those skills as well and within each
category you can get an average score so
you can kind of say like okay this one's
high and privacy but low and mental and
emotional so you kind of see those
trade-offs as well what's in each of the
scores so just for fun here are some of
the scores for various technologies that
people in our validity studies showed us
so you kind of see the six dimensions
around the circle and we had people
either say that this is a technology
that they were using currently or that
they had abandoned you can kind of
compare the different levels of burdens
so the using in this case is blue and
the abandoned is orange so this is an
iPad so the people who had abandoned it
was actually high difficulty and use for
them where's the people who are still
using it was actually low so the more
extreme is that the higher burden same
thing with the mental and emotional was
higher for the people who had abandoned
that technology but lower for that so at
time and social seemed to be about equal
four people in terms of the abandoned
versus not here's paypal so it seems
like the people who are abandon it or
abandoned because of privacy issues as
well as difficulty of use issues and a
little bit in some of the others the
numbers of each category this is the
number of people who responded without
paypal or so there were 18 who were
still using it in our set of data and a
22 would have been in it this is Fitbit
so it's interesting i was thinking i was
i would thought that physical would
actually be a more of an issue for
people but was more of an issue for the
people who are still using it and the
people who would abandon it but the
difficulty of use and privacy were the
biggest concerns for the people it's a
pretty small sample I'm so you can kind
of take the consult I got a charger so
great that going to school useless think
about that in answering right so I was
doing a party
like having to remember to do something
so even the mental and emotional so you
having to remember to use it was
something that came up there or if it
was about the time issue in terms of you
know I need to take the time out of my
day to do this and it might fit more at
a time people will be worried yeah yeah
or is dorky looking or or like the
spamming your friends sort of thing fit
into social or I don't want people know
that I'm using it I can if people aren't
just I could pull up the full set of
questions and kind of get a sense for
what's in each category but the
definitions I talked about kind of a
related to the questions in each so we
have kindle so people who were it was
interesting the the time and social
probably more time in this case was
really really high for kindle for the
people who are still using it because
they're spending a lot of time in it but
you're the people who weren't kind of
maybe abandoned it because it was easel
and this kind of highlights one of the
issues of using user burden on its own
as opposed to doing it in a set of
things within kind of computing systems
because user burden doesn't tell us
anything about value so for example they
may actually value reading on a kindle
so they're willing to have a higher time
and social burden so that's one of
things that we want to evaluate it is
how things compare when they value it
highly and we suspect that people are
much more willing to put up with burden
if they get more value out of it and
then we had gmail I was actually
surprised by the number of people that
had abandoned gmail but they didn't like
it because of difficulty of youth and
everyone was concerned about privacy but
again if they value it they may be
willing to put up with private any
privacy concerns that they have but you
I suppose maybe they had found another
email solution it was easier than gmail
for them and that's why they had a band
in it Netflix everyone thought it was a
waste of time or at least a time burden
in general a time and social and you
know for the most part you people might
have find it more of a financial burden
that was one of the few that was sort of
a more financially based thing and for
all of these people are allowed to put
enter in whatever technology they wanted
so when our future work we're going to
try and actually specifically look at
some technologies oh so this is so it's
0 to 4 is the scale so yes so this is
like a 4.5
right there so yeah it's not as bad so
right person okay yeah actually a lot of
people feel like it is valuable for what
they pay i think so i think in the
questions in the financial category were
definitely more about like this is a
good use of my money or so this is a I
don't get enough value out of this for
what I'm paying for so the questions
were around that way and then lastly
Facebook was their most popular one that
people rated and privacy burden was was
pretty high especially for the people
who felt abandoned and the time and
social were high but financial obviously
there's no money that you have to pay
and the difficulty of youth people who
abandoned it found a little bit more
difficult but yeah mechanical turk users
in the United States so honest were they
yeah we put it we didn't have a couple
people put in mechanical turk as there
so I could probably pull out that's what
they were kind of it was a long tail for
sure so these are the the more popular
ones and there but yeah so they were and
our criteria was just people who use
technology frequently and obviously
Turkish are using technology before ya
know it was i we did give us a like it
for example Facebook or GPS system we
try to give a range of like five or six
ones in there yeah there's a photoset
conical is like well there isn't a lot
of social network nowadays but net picks
and I can store probably yeah I have to
go back through like I said it was a
pretty long tail so these are the top
eight that were kind of the most common
yeah yeah absolutely yeah different
respondents like Ross different products
to see oh you know he how it just seems
to have privacy problems across
everything we could yeah we haven't done
that yet but we certainly could
mm-hmm right exactly yeah so user burden
I think this is sort of a population
thing but yeah absolutely my burden may
not be the same as James may not be the
same as you a person with a disability
he might do person like I said with the
financial it definitely depend on the
person in terms of their financial
status once you've shown us is facebook
the only one when people have banded it
or using more time and social other
people are still using it I'm not quite
sure i'm not sure i didn't make it could
be but yeah but maybe because they found
it to be a time Burton yeah it's don't
value yeah so this could be almost like
it's a time suck but they don't value it
and then it's kind of a small difference
so I'm not sure if that's we didn't run
any statistical significance on these
this is just kind of a visual actually
just put this together this week because
the first time we looked at this
available but yeah I mean they they
tried it and then stop easy or they're
not toys I mean I'm not define what
abandonment so we just said you answer
this question here for technology you
used to use but no longer so we didn't
necessarily say you tried it once and
quit you just used to use and we let
people sort of define what they meant by
that yeah good question any other sorry
yeah yeah use this to do something
that's at risk pop music okay with that
risk of losing customers potentially
yeah we haven't done that yet but I
would imagine maybe people could
regularly do this over time and if
they're starting to see burdens grow
over time then they could kind of get
some early warning yeah it could be yeah
so they could kind of have a house that
house Facebook doing today and in terms
of that I don't maybe I haven't run this
by them yet but I'll see that's a good
idea and the last one is skype but this
is actually interesting know the people
there's a really big difference between
the people who are using it they've it
and it was actually there was a most
abandoned technology in terms of the the
using versus abandon and the people who
had abandoned it just found it really
difficult to use the people who are
still using it fun it's super easy to
use so could just be you I'm not those
were all Microsoft workers or people who
work for sky / or whatnot but yeah they
felt that that was actually the biggest
difference for them and so why should we
care about reducing user burden so you
talked a little bit about abandon
but you know I think that you the user
burden can definitely lead to technology
ban it especially if it's discretional
use so things like you all of us kind of
probably complain about things that we
have to use for work you know like we
have to use email probably we probably
have to use Microsoft Word or some other
word processing software but if it's
sort of you know a game or social
network or things along those lines and
people you can stop using it because it
up I think it can limit the type of
people who'll be able to benefit from
different types of technology so
obviously a financial burden if it's
high is going to limit the type of
people who can afford to use it or
people with disabilities and things
along those lines and then just
contribute to overall negative user
experience so I kind of talked about the
end result of a lot of research now
going to kind of go back and talk to you
a little bit more about how we built up
to that yeah so solid that is something
that people would amplify or would
suppress afterwards relative to how they
would feel about it at the time they in
general right Abel Morse like they
overestimated how much the timbre matter
relative to how they might have actually
felt the food we didn't necessarily a
really great idea to sort of think about
you people who just start using a
technology versus someone who's using it
for many you of months or so cuz via
people may you I first signed up for
facebook i was like oh yeah i can check
it a couple times a day and it won't be
much of a time burden or as they've been
using it for a year they're like oh my
god i'm spending an hour a day on it
that's way more than I thought so I I
don't know if we can predict what people
will be thinking but we could certainly
kind of compare out how it changes over
time you know 12 months in and then say
12 months after I abandoned right like
am I amplifying how strong guys yeah and
we didn't ask them how long ago they had
a band in it so that maybe you a good
thing to follow up there yeah if you
value or characterize abandonment
abandon that something that's either
beneficial or lacking for people because
some people might actually click better
by abandoning things yeah and that's a
change listing yeah so the questions
kind of did we control furthers a
positive or negative abandonment and
there is some interesting work I think
there was some at ub comp last year that
was talking about like graduating from
technologies so like you needed a
technology as a support but then you
learned enough from it that you didn't
need it anymore so things like fitness
tracking technologies came up with this
you know I needed Fitbit to get an
understanding of where I was but now I
have a good understanding so I don't
need it anymore I've graduated from it
so we didn't what's that I don't know
yeah I don't know and we didn't can't we
just had a system that you're using that
you no longer use and so I think a lot
of all those things came up because a
lot of times people don't use a phone
anymore because it's obsolete and that's
not a slave working issue so that could
also be a reason why they stopped using
a technology just because you know they
stopped like google reader's stopped
yeah I abandoned it because they stopped
making it right and a lot of people
didn't like that so maybe they wanted to
keep using it but they couldn't anymore
so we didn't actually get this is the
nuance of that yeah yeah so you say in
bold you said tell us about something
abandon all those had people who were
still using stuff so where did the using
data and we had answered through one of
each so we said fill this out for a
technology that you currently use and
fill this out for technology you need to
use it no longer use that was think
there's a difference in the way we
perceive furnace Lisa where do we think
of that technology of good posture yeah
so like if I have a min my fitness
tracker I met at we feel very guilty
again cuz i might amplify his burdens I
suspect there's probably some job going
on I don't know that our scale can
necessarily capture that but I think
that's actually something that
considered for sure yeah that's true
isn't it was a good thing or a bad thing
yeah great and yeah so as I mentioned so
that was kind of the output of what we
did but this is actually build up
through a large number of studies and
technology designs that I've done so
it's probably be kind of fire hose like
in terms of summarizing a lot of stuff
that my
group is done so kind of going to talk
to you a little bit about a number of
different studies and I do put the
papers on there so if you want to learn
more or if you want to have follow-up
questions you can but still probably
pretty big overview so first thing that
we had looked at was looking at this
emotional burdens so this I come up by
working on technology for parents and
looking at tracking things like dude
does my kid have early warning signs of
autism or developmental delay a lot of
people have talked about how you they
were really scared to get that news
through a technology or tracking it made
them feel bad or like they were doing
something wrong so this this idea of
emotional burden kind of came up through
through talking to people in that
context so we ran a study of how we can
design interfaces that might convey
potentially bad news around health but
convey it in a way that minimizes
emotional burden was our kind of
question so we had interviewed doctors
and patients who'd experienced diagnosis
of a chronic condition to talk about
things like information needs and
reviewed medical training recommendation
so how do they train doctors to kind of
share this news we reviewed a lot of the
the literature from that to find out
what sort of things help with with kind
of conveying things to minimize
emotional burden around these things
because you don't want to necessarily
want to convey in a way that will cause
them to act or make them be informed as
opposed to avoiding it so things that we
talked about that we learned where you
people want to definitely want access to
information but in a way that's
sensitive and emotion of to their fears
and anxieties so things like
acknowledged e and then it's normal to
feel guilty you know you people who
didn't use their foot didn't walk maybe
he's like it's normal to feel bad that
you didn't walk today just acknowledging
that potential burden and then also
giving them actionable information is a
great thing to do as well so if you say
like you know it looks like you didn't
meet your step goal today if you
immediately gave them an action right
with that news then it went over much
better than sort of giving them no
actionable information so if you said as
suggested like next time why don't you
try you leaving the house five minutes
early to walk to the next bus stop if
you give them like a specific actionable
recommendation that came over much
better for the people that was kind of
what guided a lot of our thinking and
emotional burdens we looked at privacy
burdens a bit and this is the study had
done a couple years back with
folks at intel labs when it was still
existing but we were interested in how
people perceive things like privacy in
the home for things like you sensing
systems so but it's really hard to ask
questions about privacy without knowing
specific scenarios and which are the
context in which potential privacy
breaches what happen so what we did was
we did a four week so yeah so the
question was you know how do we what was
their receptiveness to privacy concerns
we did a four week cultural prober you
sent them home with a camera a diary and
what we called sensor proxies so these
are essentially just light sensors with
a motion sensor on it so light lights
with a motion sensor on it so you walk
by and the light turns on we put a
little ? around that and we told them to
treat that as a sensor and pretend that
when this you see this light turn on
pretend that that moment was just
captured by some sort of sensing system
to give them a sense of like oh gosh I
just walked by that and it turned on and
i maked yo and so vo baby wooden vessel
II thought of that scenario unless they
had been in it and we had them keep a
diary of those sort of incidents that
came up or the light came on and they
had a neighbor over and they didn't Dave
the neighbors like what is that light
there is that kind of got them thinking
about things like notification and
whatnot so yeah there's a lot of mental
effort and trying to remember that these
things were recording set of social
issues that came up with privacy in
terms of notification and sharing and so
those are some of the things I had kind
of got to our thinking about the privacy
burdens we did a lot of work in the the
sleep space so we did a big qualitative
study looking at how we can use
technologies for sensing sleep so we're
interested in sort of you it was it was
relatively underexplored at the time so
we wanted to look at what are the
opportunities and challenges in the
space she did literature review we did a
contextual inquiry at the sleep lab at
the University of Washington and we did
a big survey and interviews with
potential users of these technologies to
kind of do this deep insight into the
sleep space this is where the the
physical stuff came out so a lot of
people were hesitant to wear things to
bed eyo say at the time you know there
was lots of wrist-worn things they're
also like headbands and you people just
have this sort of aversion to wear
things on their body but then also
things like remembering to record some
of the mental burdens to came out of
this work was thinking about you know
Fitbit at the time you had to push a
button to start it and stop it and you
people said I go when I fall asleep at
night I always forget to do that so it
was just sort of a remembrance thing or
when I wake up in the morning first
thing I do is crawl out of bed and go
get my coffee get in the shower I'm not
wanting to log anything I'm at that
point so and then you manual tracking is
always harder when you're sleep deprived
and some people wanted things like super
super easy they said don't make me think
at all when i'm sleepy or to sleep
deprived I'm so this is sort of where
some of those other aspects of burdens
came out the we did it also work on sort
of what we call the like extremely
successful people and quantifying self
the quantified sulfur's so these are the
people who are doing all sorts of
technologies and using them to you know
almost an extreme so we thought would be
really interesting it's like okay the
people who are really successful if they
find things burdensome then what can we
learn about them yeah and so I'd say
that they are successful in sort of
accomplishing what many people have
difficulty doing and that's could be
large amounts of data about their
behavior so you know things like in the
general population if you keep a sleep
diary for even more than a day and
you're probably seeing is great where's
quantified sulfur's are doing things
like four years at a time so kind of
looking at that from that perspective so
for yes we want to know about you what
what are people learning about the ways
that they track technology and how we
can be informed by that and we did an
analysis of 52 posts so the the
quantified self community has a blog
post where they post 15-minute talks of
people sharing their experience and so
we watched 52 of these videos and coded
them for various aspects and they they
talked about that the videos have a very
set format where they're asking about
what did I do how did I do it and what
did I learn and so that would give us a
nice structure for analyzing those
things and so what we learned is that
even though these are sort of this this
case of people who are doing this
amazing thing and not only were they
able to do it they're able to stand up
and talk about it for 15 minutes so
that's why we mean by kind of these
pretty successful people and what we
learned is that you people
ponified sulfur's get burned out so we
learned that the the number one thing
that they they even called it they
deemed it the classic newbie mistake
which was trying to trap too much at
once too soon and so they would get all
excited because they're motivated at
first and they track everything at once
and then that was sort of this and they
Berg out really quickly even the highly
motor will burned out quickly they learn
they learned that not knowing the right
things to track so they often track
something like they wanted to figure out
what was causing their headaches and so
they just logged every time they had a
headache but they forgot to log things
like the context around the headache so
they had a log of like okay I had 20
headaches over the last three months and
they happened more often on Thursdays
but they forgot to track like weather
what did I eat that day to have caffeine
so didn't track any of the useful things
that would have been helpful to kind of
answer their questions so they were
annoyed that they had sort of spent all
this effort tracking all this stuff but
they didn't actually know what to do
with it and that kind of led it to the
the inconclusive data where they said or
have all this data but they couldn't
actually draw the conclusions they want
from it and lastly this is a new thing
that we've been looking at so I've been
also looking at your burdens of
technology within family context as well
and so this is a paper that we presented
at CCW this year that was looking at the
rules that family have families have
around technology use and this is kind
of getting at the social burdens of this
so our questions were how our family is
currently setting and keeping rules for
both parents and children's we had
parents describe the rules that they
have for their child and for themselves
and we had children rate the rules of
their parents have assigned them as well
as the rules that they wish to their
parents followed this is kind of getting
that kid's perspective also about what
should parents be doing and we heard a
lot of things like it be present and a
lot of kids don't want their kids their
parents to text and drive either
apparently that came up to we had a
little bit of a media around this as
well and of course the big rule that was
actually kind of a minor part of our
study was that parents were being kids
didn't want their parents posting about
them on social media meaning like don't
post pictures of me on Facebook mom and
that was actually coming up a bit and
the media covered that and thought that
was an interesting finding even though
it's kind of actually a minor part of
our study but you know what we did was
we actually surveyed to and forty-nine
parent-child dyad so the parent took a
surveyed and
I got their child to come and take the
survey and they had similar sets of
questions about themselves and the other
thing we did was ask about how hard or
easy it was to follow as well so you and
so we learned about which rich rules
that parents me that were easy to follow
versus those that were hard to follow
and your things that we learned was
obviously technology distracts from
being present and I was the number one
request of the kids their parents was to
be present with me don't look at your
phone the whole time I want you to look
at me when I'm talking to you and that
came out quite a bit especially their
younger families yep their kids awesome
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure oh seven
carries a gun and kids like people on
the phone especially the teenagers like
on social media all the time I might
take up and lock so that came up a lot
there's issues around privacy when
things got older so parents said like
their rule was that their kids had to
give them their login and password for
every account that they created of
course like a 13 year old who's just
getting started like okay mom that's
fine does the kid got older yeah that
wasn't quite as much of an issue that
was much more of an issue as a kick-out
older so there's sort of these changing
needs as the kids get older and then you
this all this management also took time
away from you studying these rules that
took time away from family time as well
so even just managing technology in
general was taking away from families
this is kind of not related to user
burden but one of our big findings was
things like that we were surprised about
was that context space rules were much
harder to follow than just straight out
banning rules so things like what i mean
by context rules was that no phones at
the dinner table was hard as opposed to
kind of activity-based fool like no
Instagram like it was actually easier
for kids to say I'm okay and it's easy
to follow the no Instagram role that is
no phones at the the dinner table so
these rules that are round like not
using the phone in certain contexts like
at church or while driving or in certain
locations are much harder to fold and
the rules that were just don't post
about yo sexual stuff or you don't talk
to strangers online those are actually
easier to follow in the ones that were
kind of these more contextual rules but
there's a stronger desire for these
contexts rules because they're more
meaningful right I don't care what
you're doing on your phone as long as
you you're not disrupting family time
so there was sort of this desire to have
more rules around context that are
actually harder to follow in force and
so I think there's an opportunity and
design for that so that was sort of
these larger sort of formative studies
that we've done that informed a lot of
our thinking around user burden and led
to sort of our initial set of the the we
started out with in our scale 120
questions and then those end up being
narrowed down to 20 so that's how we did
our developing are the constructs but
now that we have a good as you're
standing of user burden we want to know
how can we reduce it as well so what can
we do through design or through other
sorts of things to help reduce each of
these burdens so we designed a number of
different tools that try to address
different burdens and if they're all
this is what we realized is that and I
think I kind of alluded to this earlier
it's impossible to probably minimize
every single burden at once it was
there's always going to be some
trade-off so for example you might want
to minimize privacy burdens because
people very much care about their
privacy but then by lowering the privacy
burden you're raising the mental effort
associated with sort of managing that
privacy so i think privacy is pretty
important free people on facebook and
that's why why they ended up with this
pretty complex set of privacy rules
because it's impossible to sort of
minimize privacy while also minimizing
mental effort and understanding at the
same time so so each of these we talked
about kind of the burdens that we try to
prioritize in each of our designs and
how we try to address that particular
burden but in doing that sometimes we
raise the burden other ways did you have
a question my god yeah wonder out loud
how much do people feel like these
burdens are extrinsic to them versus
something that they can actually manage
so it's like oh I hate you managing
privacy but I know I can fix it you know
it's like Facebook is like doing this to
me and yeah there was some of that so in
some of it was interesting to the end to
open our interviews action you're
interviewing people about different
burdens is that people were sometimes
having trouble differentiating sort of
the content from the actual design of
the tool so for some people said like oh
there's a huge emotional burden with
facebook when people post like
depressing sad things and that's not
just like facebook's fault no it's your
friends fault right and so people had
sort of trouble separating themselves
from that and
I know this kind of tangential what
you're saying I think also your
questions are about did they feel like
they had control over the burden that
was yeah suggest that they wouldn't feel
ready like it's the thing doesn't to be
right as opposed to I'm doing this to
myself right although imagines things
like time yeah right right so yeah I
think there was enough with some of the
same people who are concerned he's a
good diction sort of felt like it was it
should be within my control but I can't
help that sort of things and there was
sort of that was probably the biggest
thing that came up was this worried
about I use it too much Netflix and read
it and stuff like that came up a lot for
for you haven't that diamond visible you
know just a percentage like my fault
versus therefore right like I'm
presumably something like financial
burden yes all gonna be always exactly
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
we hadn't looked at that angle but I
think they're interesting part to look
at your very good parents children okay
so deep i'm not sure if you notice but
the contrast between parent children
parents and children will related let's
say we so the parent wanted the child to
come off their phone i look at the
mcdonald with them yeah one of those
provides vessel do you find that usually
it was one of the tooling any pair that
wanted that or my phone because it would
be interesting raise more usually it was
one person in that bear who wanted the
other kuna i'm not the other yeah i'm
not sure we did that specific type of
analysis i suspect there might be some
of that right so like you there's always
one person in the diet who sort of more
aware than the other of that this is an
issue so like the oblivious parent is
sitting there texting while that child's
it in there like I want you to watch my
soccer game right and or yeah vs like
the the child who's like it's hard to
say i'm not sure i we'd have to look
into the data a little bit more but i
suspect there could be definitely
unequal amounts of that and some of it
had to do with also probably just values
as a family some people we were hearing
a lot of things about rules like you
know no screens between like five and
seven o'clock at night and so that was
sort of the family had set that as a
rule and so then people were more in the
same
age and then people who sort of like the
parent was like I'm just going to set
these rules and everyone's going to
follow no matter what so that it seemed
that was another fine name is that the
the rules that were sort of set together
with input from the children and
everyone in it were much more likely to
be followed than the ones that were sort
of set you know kind of authoritative
Lee or authoritarian Lee by the the
parent without input from the the child
see I suspect there was some of that
going on great so I'm going to go
through these fairly quickly because it
do I have told 130 okay so I have some a
little bit more timer um so I mentioned
I did a bunch of stuff in the sleep
space and I actually was a really
interesting area to explore different
types of burdens because there's a bunch
of stuff relating to sleep with that but
you know when we first started this work
we actually wanted to start out with and
this is sort of a reaction to the the
survey we did with the participants who
just said like I don't want to think
about this you know don't make me do
anything while I'm groggy and sleepy
tracking is really burdensome all these
sorts of things but I want to know how
to make myself healthier so there's sort
of this they didn't want to do anything
but they want to have a benefit which it
wouldn't it be great if acuity does we
thought well could we actually design
something that didn't require any sort
of input or effort at all so our first
experiment that was looking at looking
at just a passive wallpaper active
wallpaper that would update throughout
the day and inform people of when the
different types of activities might have
an impact on their sleep or not see
ideas that things like if you drink
caffeine after a certain time of day can
impact your sleep negatively if you
exercise within so many hours of going
to bed it can impact your lives and you
can impact your sleep if you drink
alcohol before a certain amount of time
then that can also impact your sleep but
then if you also start to relax if we're
going to bed that can help your sleep
but it's hard to keep track of all these
things so the idea is that all they
would do when they download it up was
set up their wake up there a deal wake
up time and their ideal sleep time does
the only entering the ahead to do and
they just let it go throughout the day
would actually update so the idea is
that this white vertical line is the
current time and then if the line is
thin that means if you did that right
now activity right now would have a
negative impact on your sleep the line
is thick if you do the activity now it
probably wouldn't have a negative impact
on this leap it is you can kind of get a
sense of the circadian rhythm going
on and throughout the day so I could
quickly glance and say okay it's 630
it's too late for coffee it's too late
for napping napping is actually really
only good at that time after lunch it's
still okay to exercise still okay to eat
alcohol woohoo but not quite time to
start relaxing yet so they've gotta get
a quick sense of that as they're doing
their other things throughout the day so
no tracking no thinking about it it was
just sort of an ambient display of what
that and we did actually find after four
weeks of use that at least eight of our
12 participants were able to increase
their their sleepiness level or star
either decrease their overall daytime
sleepiness levels just by having this
app alone so women without any effort
whatsoever we were to find some
improvement overall without any burden
whatsoever in terms of that so we kind
of said this is targeting you know we
didn't want to have people wear anything
or have a remember to track anything so
this is kind of looking at the the
mental burns and the physical burdens
trying to reduce those in particular so
another example of this was that then
then we ran the study and you people
never know what they want but they the
people in that study said like oh it
would be great if I could actually track
my caffeine use like okay you told us
before that you didn't want to track
anything and then after you use this for
a month you said you do and attract
these things say that okay well what
would tracking add to this if we were
going to add something so again we're
try to focus in on you know people don't
want to go through and earn all these
complicated things I don't have to think
very much so again we're sort of
utilizing the the lock screen here and
wanted to do these one tap manual
entries because a lot of the things
relate to sleep are actually hard to
sense automatically or a pretty onerous
to sense in general or privacy
concerning you if you log everything
then it might increase the privacy
burden so the idea was to make a super
simple super easy tracking tool for
capturing moments of your day throughout
that have an impact on your sleep so we
use the the androids lock screen widgets
and made just a button so you just have
to turn on your phone and you can tap I
had a caffeinated beverage I exercised I
had a cigarette and I her head
medication and it will create this log
of you and kind of give you this
visualization and then you can kind of
come up with these and we did have them
fill out a sleep diary in the beginning
but you could also use a just a sleep
sensing tool as well but for our study
we had them manually log
things in the beginning the day then you
can kind of get to see over time which
of the factors you're doing would have
an impact on their overall sleep quality
so you kind of get a sense of oh yeah if
I had caffeine after six o'clock it
looks like I got worse sleep that night
so you can kind of start to make those
connections together we still don't
think this is the best I do it I'll
allude to that in a minute but you know
the idea was just to make it super dead
simple no time reducing the time burden
reducing the mental effort associated
with that we also found that just by
having it on the lock screen it was a
great reminder to just log it quickly so
it was also reducing sort of the heaven
remember oh I gotta go to do that
because they'd look at their phone and
say oh yep i had i'm drinking coffee
right now do it right there so did a
good job of minimizing those particular
burdens also in the sleep space we
wanted to look at things like looking at
the environmental and how environment
and how that can have an impact on sleep
so things like the light levels the
temperature levels the sound levels in
the room can all have an impact on sleep
again people want to try and figure out
what their disruptors were since they're
different for different people so we
developed a tool that just had a set of
sensors that was in the bedroom and gave
people just a really quick feedback that
the ideal conditions in the room or
either present or not present for those
things and so you know the sleep
literature recommends keeping your
bedroom between like you I think 58
degrees and 70 degrees so we gave him
just a green light or red light if
they're within the recommended range as
well as light levels and noise levels
and we had motion sensors for detecting
things like neopets in the room or
children coming in and those sorts of
things so but this is sort of to give
people a broad understanding of it and
then we were able to generate graphs of
the different patterns under sleep
levels and combination with those
environmental sensors but this is
actually we in we recorded videos to the
goog wonder they're so the videos of the
bedroom were actually pretty privacy
invasive but they were necessary for
people to sort of investigate what was
going on say to really think about like
how to control the privacy there so we
had really quick one touch turn on and
off the camera or just the recording
as well as you know from our studies
feel things happen in the bedroom that
you don't want recorded especially if
you have a partner and so we had a
really quickly delete last hour as well
as a delete more we had to be able to do
this in such a way that we could kind of
delete the things they didn't want to
see but still make it useful so if they
want to go in and do this analysis of yo
the light levels and where they actually
Bo impacting my sleep or not so they
still need to be useful to them without
while trying to minimize the privacy
burden so that was thing again we
learned that just capturing things isn't
enough so i'm going to talk about what
we're going to do next in that regard
this one was more about we did a project
looking at how the visually impaired
might be able to be helped with exercise
and the idea that many exercise classes
and X or games are not accessible
because they require you to line up your
body with the screen and if you can't
see the screen and obviously you can't
do that so my student Kyle rector did a
project looking at you how you make a
yoga based game that you only uses the
visual channel to help people with
things like correcting yoga postures and
be able to perform exercise that was
sort of minimizing the difficult to your
accessibility issues and then the idea
that most of the time if they want to do
an exercise class like go to a yoga
class many people especially they live
remotely have to travel large distances
to get to those special classes that are
accessible so that was sort of reducing
the time burden there um I'm going to
quickly go through this since I'm
running a little bit on time but the
other thing we want to look at this was
in the family context as well but a lot
of because parents were concerned about
the amount of time that their families
were using on technology we developed a
tool called my time this is also great
presented at Chi next month but looking
at letting people will determine which
of their apps on their phone our time
wasting or disruptive to the family and
monitoring those use over time so the
ideas they could declare candy crush and
Facebook and Twitter and all these tools
as being kind of time-wasting or
disruptive to their families and it
would track those and give them a goal
so my goal is to spend only 20 minutes
per day on these
and they were also to encourage them to
do other things they were at the PD and
the day they're encouraged to enter a
goal for the day that they would like to
do instead of doing these things so they
did I kill go for a walk outside or talk
with my family if you a lot of times
like spend time with my family was the
biggest thing there so we did a multiple
baseline study where they had the
intervention for or they didn't have the
intervention for about a week and we
randomized that and they switched over
to using it and we actually saw just a
twenty-one percent decrease in the
amount of times just with a simple
intervention we were able to show a
twenty-one percent decrease in the
amount of time on time wasting apps just
with the simple intervention there
lastly I talked about the sleep stuff
and how it was not so useful to just
collect a bunch of data and actually
you're doing it in a more systematic way
will help people find the answers to the
questions that they want to be able to
answer so we thought about how we can
help people run little mini self
experiments to answer those questions so
most of what people wanted to get out
and this came a lot from the quantified
self stuff people are tracking these
things because they had a specific
question what's causing my headaches you
why do I have abdominal pain you what's
disrupting my sleep at night and you a
lot of the tools will allow you to sort
of collect all this data and you have to
sort of make that conclusion on your own
but they're actually not really able to
make that connection for you but what
you really need to do is actually do
some days you control something and some
days you take that out and so you look
at what happens on those days so we're
developing a tool right now to allow
people to do these self experiments
starting with irritable bowel syndrome
but also looking at things like and
insomnia and smoking cravings but
looking at how we can allow people to
test things like lactose is lactose
what's causing my upset stomach we will
randomize them to an 8 to 12 day
randomized trial and we tell them to
basically you'll eat your normal
breakfast but remove you'll replace it
with lactose free milk on these days so
it will randomize them to which days
they drink the lactose free milk and
then the other days they have it and
then we have them log their symptoms and
so we have some visualizations to help
them look at you know these are the days
that you know if they're testing
caffeine these are the days that I had
caffeine and what my symptoms were like
and use of these of no caffeine
and yeah we're working on it we're
supposed to still work in progress but
we're also should experiment things like
your significance and p-values and that
sort of thing but turns out most people
don't really get that so just looking at
it visually was actually much more
helpful for people and give you a
recommendation that it's highly likely
that your symptoms are caused by
caffeine or not caused by caffeine and
giving them feedback there and lastly
your I mentioned the and the the very
beginning a lot of this work was was
motivated by your parents having this
emotional burden associated with things
like tracking development and their
young kids so this is a project that we
were looking at for helping parents from
of children ages zero to five track
developmental progress and identify
early if they have signs of
developmental delay like things like
speech delays or anxiety disorders or
things along those lines and we wanted
to do this in a way that was motivating
to people to be able to do this would
reduce the emotional burden associated
with this this idea that something could
be wrong with your kid and also do it in
a way that was accessible so we're
working with the state of Washington and
they had the goal of screening every
single child in the state regardless of
access to technology or income levels
and there so we had to kind of goals
that this one which was reducing the
financial burden of people who couldn't
necessarily afford smartphones and
things along those lines as well as
reducing the emotional burdens and the
mental burdens associated with this
activity so our solution what we ended
up doing here was actually not one tool
but it ended up being an ecosystem of
tools that all would meet people to
where they were and allow them to use
whatever technologies were most useful
to them so we have a website that also
is accessible via mobile phone we have a
Twitter based tool where they can
actually answer developmental questions
through Twitter as well as a text
messaging only version that they can
answer developmental screening questions
just through text message so the idea
being didn't have internet at home they
could use just a text messaging tool to
reduce financial burdens of people who
didn't have access to that technology
and then also for the emotional burden
you we did a lot of work on trying to
come up with a visualization that would
show the kids developmental progress and
we looked at we showed them things like
graphs and percentile charts and those
all perform very poorly in terms of like
making people anxious about their kids
so
instead we used or this metaphor of
their child growing and if they're lower
in a particular developmental category
it's just that there tree your child
just hadn't grown up yet so they weren't
necessarily behind but it was enough to
convey the information and encourage
people to take action on it but not yet
show them on a percentile chart that
their kid is you know to second
percentile so that was really
nerve-racking to a lot of people I know
what there's those really quickly but do
you guys have any questions on any of
those have you run any problems with
like that IPA try to step in and say oh
you're getting people medical advice
about like whether they're lactose
intolerant yeah so um yeah so the FDA is
pretty strict guidelines and if it's a
diagnosis or treatment of a condition
and yeah but if it's sort of lifestyle
decisions then that sort of is in this
gray area that's not necessary under
their purview so from their perspective
controlling your diet and stuff isn't
necessarily an own way of treating
irritable bowel syndrome so it's not
seen as being treated as sort of a kind
of lifestyle choice and so it sort of
falls into that area but we did write an
article on sort of the co
self-experimentation in general and you
could self experiment with your anxiety
meds you could self experiment with
other things and we specifically call
out in that paper that you know please
don't self experiment on things without
what things like medication without a
doctor's guidance because people could
use that tool to do those things and
that would be concerning if they were
doing that on their own but yeah it does
depend on the domain and kind of what
you're trying but if you were sort of
testing whether or not a medication was
helpful for irritable bowel syndrome it
might start to fall under that but we're
in a pretty open platform right now so
people can come itself define what they
want and try their own things but we do
recommend not to do those particular
things if I'm relationship doing any
cause and effect you can yeah what I
mean is just set up cause is in fact
they collected on though and then is
that work know so when you were actually
randomizing people pay so there's a
problem was sort of like looking at just
collecting data and setting those
variables after the fact is that you
know it could be any number of things
that impacted that so if you just say
like okay show me all the days that I
drank caffeine and what my sleep elavil
is like that day well it could be that
you drink more caffeine
you were tired and therefore it was
infecting your thing so we wanted to try
to minimize that altogether which is why
we do this random assignment so this is
more before the fact and what you're
going to track so you were sending today
don't drink any caffeine after three
o'clock tomorrow drink caffeine at six
o'clock and you know the alternate on
those days and I will minimize a lot of
those other things as opposed to like oh
I had a stressful work day so I had
caffeine that day what turns out the
stress was the cause of your sleep and
not the actual caffeine it was so that's
sort of trying to isolate the particular
ones which is why you're doing any sort
of after the fact correlations is
problematic yeah yeah so that's one of
it yeah you hit it on one of the
important things so you honestly they do
double-blind studies and you met it
medicine for a reason and you thought
about things like you know if it was
like a lactose free milk you know like
your partner can sneak you on some days
you know like they could sneak in the
lactose free milk and you wouldn't know
it but that is something that we
wouldn't necessary have to control but
you know one of the things that's okay
for this is that you what we want to do
is a perceive reduction of symptoms and
you know most of the people who are
doing this one of the impact that they
were having on them and so our scales
are actually pretty well designed in
terms of like it was more impact on
their day as opposed to like this kind
of subjective feeling so and that's a
little bit more so we try to keep with
more objective measures for that because
there's a possibility of bow
effect in some of these cases so as much
as we can do to sort of look at the
objectiveness of it as opposed to the
subjective rating and you know in some
cases placebo is ok too yeah let's see
what works in some cases so if that's
works and minimizing their symptoms
maybe it's okay too yeah that's true
let's run like a champ okey dokey that
is what being some sort of similar yes
all right what is that sorry the you
wanted on a beauty sleep oh yeah um so
the parents were oh so ism it was
automatically tweeted through our tool
there and parents would just say yes
sometimes they're not yet it wasn't sort
of doing the smart analysis of things
there are people who are looking at some
of that stuff we weren't we were just
looking at parents explicitly answering
the question yeah the questions get
asked is this like a one-time thing or
like maybe your minds
yeah good question so it's actually a
set of 22 questionnaires over a
five-year period so we're looking at and
there's 30 questions / questionnaire so
we're looking at you over and over 300
question more than that over the
lifetime of a child and that's per kid
too so you've multiple kids you have to
answer them for each child so that was
why we wanted to go meet them throughout
their it depends on the age of the child
actually so there's a lot more questions
and the kid is younger but then when
they get older it's like one
questionnaire every six months as
opposed to when they're younger it's
like one questionnaire every month so it
depended on not but for Twitter we were
tweeting out one question a day and then
for the text messaging we actually did
it differently basically if you answer a
question it sends you another one
immediately OC ideas you could actually
answer them all in one sitting and the
reason for that was because in talking
with advocates for Latino families they
said a lot of times they would get
prepaid phones and turn them off so you
couldn't necessarily space it out so
it's like one question per day because
they may not have their phone on after
they turn it off because they had a
prepaid plan and they ran out of minutes
so then we were able to kind of answer
them all on one when setting there so
just in conclusion um we have some just
general strategies that we've sort of
try to bubble up as ways of reducing
user burden in general first is that you
embedding actions into activities that
people are already doing is really
successful way of doing that so this was
apparent in our baby step stool where
people are already on Twitter and
they're already doing other things so we
can also just ask them questions all
they're doing those things so if
somebody's already doing something
that's a great way to sort of also add
on something that they're doing
providing multiple options for achieving
goals so you know obviously if some
people find some type of technology more
burdensome than another you're giving
them multiple options will help reduce
burden in general because then they can
choose the tool that they're they're
most comfortable with try to and this is
sort of a kind of platitude of
human-computer interaction in general
but know your users know what's most
burdens are most important to them
knowing your users will really help you
sort of prioritize which ones because
again you can't reduce them all at once
and yet figure out what those trade-offs
are if you raise one
lower one burglar you raise another so
figure out what those trade-offs are
going to be and then this is sort of
getting a little bit of that value
question so we found that people are
really motivated who are really motivate
that quantified sulfur's were willing to
put up with like large amounts of burden
because they were highly motivated where
someone who's just kind of curious oh
you I want to see what my levels are
like you know they were much less likely
to put up with with you know large
amounts of user burden so try to figure
out you the motivation level of your
user and try to match the burden with
that particular motivation level and
then finally through all of this yeah we
realized that like data is actually
pretty burdensome in general it so I
kind of you know we're in this big data
let's collect all the data that we can
but the more data you have the more time
it takes to do the more privacy burdens
that reduce it comes up the mark that
you have to think about it so that was
what we were thinking a lot with our
self-experimentation stuff is like
what's the minimum amount of things that
we actually have to answer to be able to
come up with the conclusions that we had
so with our self-experimentation all
they have to do is stick to the plan and
record their symptoms that's it they
don't have to record what they ate they
just have to stick to the plan so they
don't have to record anything so we try
to narrow it down to the minimum amount
of data needed to actually answer the
question that they wanted to do so that
was another key thing um next steps so
we want to try to keep refining this
model as well as the validate measure
you guys actually gave me a lot of good
ideas for how to to work on that and one
of the other things is that our scale
right now only works for people who have
already used the technology we'd love to
be able to know early on and the early
stage prototyping if we can sort of
predict it or no earlier on while we're
designing it that this is going to have
a burden so we're trying to think of
ideas of how we can try and learn that
earlier on without having to have them
actually use the technology in the first
place so i have many amazing students i
try to put their names up wherever
possible and lots of cool people gave me
money so thanks to them and thanks to
you guys
you